[Music]
[Applause]
what time is it
wait what your is it what right I forgot
about yesterday
okay iPhone 7 you will now live in here
for the 10th anniversary of the iPhone
I'm gonna live with this relic for a
full week I mean how bad could it be
oh okay browser ready to live in the
past today I guess I'm not checking
Instagram or snapchat or The Wall Street
Journal app but at least I have facebook
on the mobile web sorta man this web
browser was revolutionary Siri Siri
right Siri not even a fetus yet Alexa
weather right now in New York it's 81
degrees okay
this phone is super adorable look how
little like a little baby okay no not as
cute as you browser yeah yeah I'll walk
you now browser hold still hold still
hold still
this thing can't even shoot video sad
okay that's a keeper
actually this one is aren't I good you
spoke too soon low light shots are bad
and blurry I mean this thing didn't even
have a flash but you know what it does
have a headphone port now that's
innovation whoo I forgot you needed an
arrow rimmed 3.5 millimeter plug or a
dongle even ten years ago you needed a
dongle screw Spotify or Apple music look
who's got an iPod app with the cover art
carousel we never gets old huh more
coffee why is there always a line here
hmm let me see what our president we get
I bet you $10 this doesn't load by the
time I order a doughnut and coffee or by
the time I eat my donut I win fun fact I
had to pop in a t-mobile SIM card
because AT&T no longer has a 2g network
all right I've got to get to work ooh
look at me and my fancy graphics
whatever
look at this touch calculator I have no
idea what this meeting is about crap I'm
low on battery - either you guys have a
charge of the original iPhone here sure
yeah it's on my desk under my VHS copy
of beaches ha who needs this when you
have it fixed you mean maybe what
everyone needs to know I'm typing on
glass I mean before this all you had was
t9 word or a mini desktop keyboard
where's that pizza place again oh right
midday battery drain hello anyone almost
charged nope now nope
how about now nope ooh
Elsa time to take a selfie oh wait no
front-facing camera
deep thought if we existed but the
front-facing camera didn't did selfies
exist yeah 12 hours of living in 2007 is
about all I can take
ooh please open please freedom the slow
2g speeds the battery drain anxiety no
apps and mean people are mean lady your
phone is so old
my Grammy just liked it on Facebook
yeah it was a rough day but sometimes we
need to visit the past to remind
ourselves of just how far we've come
you